et donc je vois pas ce qui s'est passé
si capable de vous pour être interpellé
hier c'est la déception qui domine ici
au stade pierre aliker la martinique de
joie pas la finale elle était battue de
visa importe qu l'assaut et que ce soit
une finale jamaïque carrasso et en match
pour la troisième place
non tu découpes ian merci de votre
attention et on se retrouve avec toi la
complicité d'alfred petit noir qui a
commenté ce match ici c'est vrai que
vous n'attendez pas si naïve mais on
voudrait demander de signer ou verizon
ont ce que cette équipe de curaçao est
venue gâcher la fête ici au stade pierre
aliker
selon vous qu'est ce qui s'est passé
pour que le technicien qui s'est passé
je dois dire que c'est sur les quatre
équipes il y avait deux nations grâce
aux jamais que ce sont des équipes qui
ont beaucoup de moyens pour se préparer
et des moyens que l'on a préparé sa
jamaïque alors oui des moyens plus de
joie de plus haut niveau que nous voilà
est donc la différence se fait là
cette équipe de cuba sobon on est
surpris parce que c'est la première fois
qu'on la voit jouer
c'est une équipe qui a de petits joueurs
comme les ex travailleurs et aux
championnats des techniques anglais
technique due au gel et qui sont qui ont
dominé pratiquement techniquement et
physiquement le milieu de terrain et là
on se rend sans coup dur pour le
football martiniquais pas ce qu'est la
ligue misait beaucoup sur cette
compétition et donc c'est un coup dur
pour le football martiniquais la
sélection qui n'est pas en finale oui
parfaitement c'est dommage parce que
nous sommes qualifiés pour la gold cup
gagnée se retrouvent en finale et gagner
c'est surtout loin ce serait très bien
psychologiquement pour l'autre équipe
qui va en quelque peu prochainement
donc c'est dommage c'est dommage c'est
la tristesse et moi je suis comme
mission de côté
voilà merci alpha le côté droit qui
entraîneurs éducateurs et je rappelle
donc les deux temps forts ces dimanches
sur hbo martinique première tout d'abord
la troisième place le match entre la
martinique et la guyane
suivi de la crown finale à savoir
jamaïque carrasso merci de
contraventions et bonne nuit à tous